Hello there!
Is that, is that Cohen?
What are you looking for Christmas this year, Cohen?
A choo-choo train?
And what would Mommy and Daddy like for Christmas?
A big TV.
What I need is new socks and underwear.
An Android tablet.
While the guests told their Christmas wishes to good old Saint Nick,...
...WestJetters took notes and got ready to shop quick.
It was a great rush, with the two flights in the air,...
...to get all those presents, not a moment to spare!
Thanks for flying with us at WestJet.
Sit back, relax and enjoy the rest of your flight.
But was everything ready?
We all had to wait for the moment of truth at carousel eight.
Merry Christmas!
No way!
The guests never expected what they asked of Saint Nick would actually appear.
It was all quite a trick.
A WestJetter would say, "It was more than mere fun."
"Miracles do happen when we all work as one."
We'll give Santa the last word on this most special night.
Merry Christmas to all and to all a good flight!